>>> OKAY, PELOTON, LET'S GO!
>> ONLY PELOTON DELIVERS 24/7
NONSTOP MOTIVATION FROM
WORLD-CLASS INSTRUCTORS RIGHT IN
YOUR HOME.
>> YOU SMASHED IT!
>> WHAT IF YOU'RE THE KIND OF
PERSON WHO DOESN'T RESPOND TO
ENCOURAGEMENT?
>> YOU DID THIS!
>> IF I HEAR THE PHRASE "YOU CAN
DO IT," I LITERALLY WON'T, JUST
TO PROVE A POINT.
>> IF ANYONE YELLS THAT I CAN DO
ONE MORE, I WILL IMMEDIATELY GET
OFF THIS THING, UNPLUG IT, AND
GO SMOKE.
>> I CANNOT BE CHEER-LEADED, I
KNOW MYSELF.
>> FOR THOSE PEOPLE WE
INTRODUCE "PELO-TAUNT."
THE ONLY EXERCISE BIKE THAT
PROVIDES YOU PERSONALIZED,
AT-HOME NEGATIVE REINFORCEMENT,
AND RELENTLESS CRITICISM.
>> READY TO DO THIS?
>> NO.
>> I DON'T GIVE A [ BLEEP ], I
GET PAID EITHER WAY.
>> HEY, I GUESS I COULD DO A
LITTLE BIT, LOOK!
COME BACK!
>> USING PATENTED PASSIVE
AGGRESSION, EACH PELO-TAUNT
INSTRUCTOR WILL PULL FROM A
TOOLKIT OF EMOTIONAL
MANIPULATION STYLES GUARANTEED
TO GET THE LAZIEST CYCLIST
MOVING.
TECHNIQUES SUCH AS SNOTTY
DISDAIN.
>> REALLY NICE BIG T-SHIRT.
DO YOU WEAR THIS TO SWIM?
>> NO.
>> WELL, THANKS FOR WEARING IT
HERE.
>> INSINCERE PRAISE.
>> OKAY, SUSAN, I KNOW YOU JUST
HAD A BABY SO GO AT YOUR OWN
PACE.
>> WHAT?
I DIDN'T HAVE A BABY.
>> OH.
ARE YOU SURE YOU DIDN'T?
>> YEAH.
>> OH.
OKAY.
WELL, MAYBE ONE DAY.
>> AND A PLUG-IN ATTACHMENT
STYLE THAT WILL PUT YOU IN A
STATE OF COMPLETE CODEPENDANCE.
>> I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
TO DO --
>> SHOULD I GO UP A LEVEL?
>> I THINK YOU SHOULD JUST NOT
TALK.
>> IF YOU WANT TO TALK TO ME,
I'M RIGHT HERE.
LOOK, LOOK AT ME, GUYS!
I'M DOING IT!
>> NO CORNY INSPIRATIONAL
SPEECHES HERE.
JUST WITHERING JUDGMENT SURE TO
GET YOUR HEART PUMPING AND YOUR
BRAIN THINKING, "AM I BAD?"
>> GIVE IT UP FOR MIKE WHO'S
WORKING OUT IN HIS GARAGE!
>> OH, NO, THIS IS MY LIVING
ROOM.
>> WHAT?
>> I FEEL MENTALLY BROKEN DOWN,
BUT HEY, I CAN SEE MY ABS.
>> I HATE EXERCISE, BUT I HATE
SARAH MORE.
>> THIS IS YOU --
>> PELO-TAUNT HAS ALL THE
UPGRADED FEATURES THAT KEEP YOU
MOVING OUT OF SPITE.
FEATURES LIKE GASLIGHTING YOU
ABOUT HOW FAR YOU'VE GONE.
>> HEY, IT SAID I DID FOUR RIDES
BUT I DID FIVE.
>> NO, I THINK YOU DID FOUR.
IT'S A COMPUTER.
>> LIVE VIDEO OF YOUR OWN ASS
FROM BEHIND WITH AN EXAGGERATED
FISHEYE LENS.
>> OH GOD, IS THAT MINE?
>> A CONSTANT PICTURE-IN-PICTURE
OF AN ELDERLY WOMAN WHO'S, LIKE,
1,000 TIMES BETTER THAN YOU.
>> IS THERE A WAY TO TURN IT
OFF?
SHE'S KICKING MY ASS!
>> A HUMILIATING SOUNDTRACK THAT
WILL MAKE YOU FEEL STUPID.
[ CIRCUS MUSIC ]
>> AND -- STOP!
THAT WAS GOOD.
>> IT WAS?
>> PELO-TAUNT.
ALSO AVAILABLE IN "MOM."
>> WELL, THIS WAS A DUMB THING
TO BUY.
GREAT JOB, MIKE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]